au bar dit oui
[Musique]
les chéris vous allez devoir répondre en
mangeant l'aliment c'est dans la chanson
c'est parti premier titre
[Musique]
et
voilà un artiste chocolat
deuxième type
[Musique]
il a déjà mangé ça y est sébastien
lessard dit
charles
[Musique]
las ketchup
las ketchup très bon attendiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jours
[Applaudissements]
mais pas
[Musique]
hoballah julie cacao pendant fait la
barbe aux sourires aux moeurs et la
banque un mot sourire mardi
[Musique]
ouais alors qu plaît allez sourire ou
patrick bruel
[Musique]
edel comme est belle cette chanson cyril
alors vous la gâcher un peu non moi
j'adore cette émission vous lagache est
plus que temps mais jamais tout je me
mets tout dans la bouche j'ai pu le
début est une matheuse jamais il ya un
moment là je ne peux pas rentrer là
dedans
[Musique]